[Música]
a mediados de los 90 el internet no
tenía más de un par de años de haber
llegado al perú yo todavía era
estudiante de sociología y asistente en
grabé una ong de investigación en
políticas públicas que en esa época
además tenía muchos investigadores que
regresaban de su doctorado con correo
electrónico el cual querían seguir
teniendo acceso para comunicarse con sus
colegas con los que había interactuado
en el posgrado por esa razón grade era
miembro de la red científica peruana la
rcp el primer proveedor de internet en
el perú y tenía un tipo de servicios que
le permitían manejar varias cuentas de
correo independientemente
en esos años la conexión a internet se
usaba por medio de las mismas líneas
telefónicas agregando un pequeño aparato
llamado módem que hacía un ruido in
winding cuando estaba conectando cástulo
pudieran escuchar
como yo tenía facilidad en el uso de las
computadoras me habían asignado también
la tarea de hacer tres o cuatro
conexiones al día y el módem para que
los correos entren y salgan
los modos en ese entonces tenían una
velocidad de 28 kbits por segundo hoy la
conexión la velocidad de su internet se
mide en mega gigabits por segundo
conforme fue pasando el tiempo había
cada vez más correos y los tiempos de
conexión se hacían interminables me
pasaba horas escuchando el sonido ese y
viendo pasar 11 los correos en la
pantalla
llegó un momento en el que ya no
podíamos seguir creciendo y teníamos que
empezar a usar un servidor de correo
para poder gestionar las distintas
direcciones y creciente número de
mensajes diarios que teníamos
el problema fue que ese servidor de
correo estaba fuera de todo presupuesto
en esa época casi no existía gasto de
internet más que el consumo de minutos
meses atrás yo había aprendido a navegar
usando el word wide web www que ustedes
conocen y con él la navegación en tiempo
real y con interfase gráfica
pensé que era imposible que no hubiera
otras opciones digamos a este servidor
tan caro entonces una tarde me sentí
absolutamente dispuesto a no volver a
pararme hasta no encontrar una solución
hice innumerables búsquedas en los
distintos buscadores que existían en ese
entonces todas las opciones eran igual
de caras
mientras que me tomaba la enésima taza
de café vi una pequeña nota que decía
algo así como para universidades y ongs
no servidor gratuito
y grade como ya les conté era una ong
con solo mi correo punto org p puede
descargar el software en ese mismo
instante
ahora sólo quedaba instalarlo
configurarlo y que funcione
correctamente
hasta antes de ese día yo no había
instalado algo así en mi vida
mientras que a los lejos se escuchaba a
los pájaros cantar en pleno amanecer
termine de hacer las pruebas comprobé
que el servidor de correo estaba 100%
operativo había migrado las direcciones
de correo electrónico de unas 30
personas tal vez un poco más
en esa época nadie enseñaba este tipo de
cosas en las facultades de ingeniería y
este software que yo había encontrado
tenía menos de tres meses de lanzado leí
los manuales visite los foros youtube
sería fundado diez años después
todavía se me pone la piel de gallina
recordando lo que sentí esa mañana tenía
claro que en ese momento no habían más
de 100 personas en el mundo que sabían
hacer lo que yo acababa de aprender por
mi cuenta en una sola noche por años no
hubo otra instalación de ese tipo en el
perú yo soy sandro marcone director de
cultura digital punto p y me dedico a
transformar la educación en base al
internet y el autoaprendizaje
antes de vivir esa experiencia de
aprendizaje yo andaba bastante perdido
en realidad tenía dos trabajos y
estudiar en la universidad pero en
realidad nada lograba motivar
el descubrimiento de internet como una
fuente inagotable de información y
conocimiento transformó mi vida
un par de años después de esa noche dejé
la sociología y grabé y me fui a
trabajar a la red científica peruana la
rcp a dirigir la oficina de desarrollo
web ahí se hizo el primer buscador
peruano las primeras webs del gobierno
la primera cámara web en vivo en la
plaza de armas del cusco el primer
periodo periódico digital el primer
portal etcétera luego fui el primer
director del proyecto nacional de uso de
tecnologías en la educación el proyecto
huascarán
intenté hacer la primera versión peruana
de second life la primera página web de
cupones de descuentos y el primer centro
comercial online muchas cosas salieron
muy mal pero muchas otras muy bien
así llegó marzo del 2020 y tuvimos que
hacer distanciamiento social obligatorio
y las escuelas se cerraron los maestros
y las maestras los niños y las niñas las
familias la hemos tenido muy difícil
el poco acceso a equipamiento sólo el 30
por ciento de los hogares tiene una
computadora en casa y la baja calidad de
la conexión de internet ha hecho todo
mucho más complicado
hay al menos 2 millones de familias que
solo pueden usar whatsapp para hacer
clases y esa no es una herramienta
pensada para la educación
la solución a largo plazo tiene que ver
con mejorar las condiciones de
infraestructura y de equipamiento a
nivel nacional
pero en el día a día quien ayuda a estas
familias en cultura digital punto p
adecuamos una metodología pedagógica
para que se pueda usar vía whatsapp y
empezamos a dictar el taller de nueva
clase invertida en whatsapp de manera
gratuita han participado más de 1000
docentes quienes atienden a su vez a más
de 30.000 estudiantes
me entusiasman los proyectos pioneros
imaginar y diseñar las cosas desde cero
hacer cosas que no se han hecho antes
estoy convencido que puedo aprenderlo
todo y desde ahí siempre encontrar
soluciones
el autoaprendizaje es tu nueva fuente de
poder